okay hello everyone it's Michael Volos
from orderflows and this is my
orderflows market analysis for Thursday
July 27 2017 and oh what a what a day
today we had uh Dow closing at record
highs basically on the back of Verizon
and Boeing um Verizon was up about uh
7.5% uh but uh broader exchange uh
broader indices were lower yet uh NASDAQ
was down about Point uh just about over
a half a percent Apple was down quite a
bit today it was down almost 2% um
although we closed lower in NASDAQ and
S&P it was well off our lows for the day
and uh there's also you know I think
what was adding to some of the drop was
uh Dow Jones transports were down about
3% and you know usually when you get the
transports down uh quite a bit it's you
know a warning signal to uh some of
these old school uh traders that you
know get ready for an equities pullback
but um but we'll see we'll see so uh
before I jump into it uh go through a
brief disclaimer this presentation is
for educational and informational
purposes only it should not be
considered a solicitation VI or sell a
Futures Contract or make any other type
of investment decision Futures Trading
contain substantial risk and is not for
every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
once Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
pass forance is not necessarily
indicative of future results and the
tools I'm going to talk about in this uh
presentation that I'm going to be using
in the charts are the order flows Trader
the volume footprint chart and the Delta
scalper
so you know what do I mean when we had
the this this big pullback if if you go
to the daily chart really quick here in
the snps this is the S&P daily
chart you can see early in the morning
we're up here at our highs uh new
contract highs 248 and a uh what was
that 80 and a half but then uh you know
later in the session you know first
couple hours until from the cash open
until you know 10:00 a.m. it was just
hanging around in here around
uh 77 78 79 know down to 76 we were just
in that very tight range extremely
boring morning extremely boring morning
and then we broke we broke we traded all
the way down to uh what is that 57 and
uh 57 even before recovering back up to
uh 70 2 and a qu so well it looks like
you're just down marginally we were down
quite a bit you know we took out
yesterday's low we took out the low from
two days ago took out you know um the
19th
was last Wednesday took out that low so
um me we didn't take out the the low of
this of this uh 18th but we didn't take
out last week's low but you know we took
out obviously this week's low we took
about most of the lows earlier um this
week
now the interesting thing
was again you know early in the
session I'll I'll get the 10 range chart
up here really quick just you know it'll
make explanation a lot easier is
uh if you ever you know if you've
ever worked with uh volume
profile okay here this is the volume
profile sorry here uh
what day is this at
20 where am I here bear with me
here okay so
on
the 25th okay this is the volume profile
for the
25th value area high you're looking here
around 2477 A5 value area low around
2474 that's why I drew these lines here
I've had these lines up here since
yesterday actually okay so this was on
uh Tuesday
25th and then on the 26th which was
Wednesday yesterday again also on the
volume profile you're basically looking
at around the same value area right
around uh 77 and a half high value area
high 74 low okay now
where are we here so we came into the
session this
morning sorry no then uh this is the 26
here okay and yesterday if you if you
remember we did get down below the value
area low and then we did it again later
in the session and made a new low by a
tick then rally back up in there okay
then this morning we were trading just
on this is today already here so you
know we made the high just after the
cash open
and we just you know we're trading
within that value area for you know most
of the morning you know we did pop up
here you know this
bar here at um 11:31 it took about 2
hours to form and you know honestly I
was I was hoping you know me I'm an
optimist right I like the market to
Rally rather than sell off but we
couldn't we couldn't we couldn't take
out that high it was really struggling
um then we come back inside the value
area okay so we can't ex you know we
can't make a move above the value area
um you know extend the move higher and
make new highs
and do much so what am I going to look
for I'm going to look for if we're going
to trade through the value area and what
happens is we get down to the value area
low yesterday's value area low and the
and the same value area low as U two
days ago which you know is not very
often you get the same value area um for
two days in a row but you know once you
when you break that Watch What Happens
boom you get a lot lot of selling coming
in here strong negative Deltas 4,200
4,700 um we got a bunch of stacked
imbalances you know and this is at 74
okay
now yesterday's low is what one and a
half here so it's just right in here as
well so boom we take out yesterday's low
so we're below the value area for the
last two days you know below yesterday's
low and you know it that's you know
you're just looking at a bearish market
right now and what happens is we we come
off we trade all the way down you know
it's just all selling it's just all
dominated by selling you had the one bar
here you know a little bit of buying but
look at these Deltas they're strong 1200
6,000 6,000 you know stronger than what
you were earlier 4,000
4,000 and you just you keep selling off
keeps on off you're looking for some
buying to come in you know some came in
here honestly at uh
1229 you had this Divergence no ratio
you didn't get much of a bounce you know
it bounced up about a point off the
point and a the here at UH 60 and2 60
and 3/4 we did get back up to uh you
know 63 and 3/4 I think it was before
coming down again you get some weak
buying in here some positive Deltas 600
600 um then you get down here to this
low another Divergence and then you
rally up for it but really the the big
thing was uh for me at least was was
getting below this value area low which
we had for the last two
days you know so to me that was quite a
powerful level to to blow
through okay so again you just to to
touch on volume profile you know that
that's one of the benefits of using
things like Market profile orderflow
volume profiles because you know if
you're just looking at a bar chart you
know this one kills me about uh quote
price action Traders oh I'm watching The
Price action well you don't know where
value is right and if you're just
looking at this bar here you know even
though it's you know it opened here
closed up here big green bar you know it
looks like oh this is your body but you
know really for this day on the
25th your value area is up here in the
wick right and you know again if if
you're not noticing it let's just you
know let's go back here to this day the
25th all right what what was the day
what did it look like you know this is
where we opened on the 25th here
and you know so you got like this big
green candle but you know it's it's kind
of misleading this is where all the
trading was during the day it was up
here in the
wick right and it just it settled down
here so you know even though it looked
like yeah it was a strong you know a
nice update you know people I I think a
lot of Candlestick guys right they they
just look at the uh what do you call it
the wick they they really disregard this
and think okay yeah you know I think lot
of trading happened here when it didn't
you know it's this
area up in
here right from 70 4 to you know
basically 74 to 78 you know right in
here uh draw it in
here 77 and 3/4 so you know this
was this area here this was the value
area
right right in here you can see it right
here and then even for the next day you
know that's where all the value that's
where all the volume was right in there
right in here so you know we got through
there we broke through there finally um
you know yesterday we poked through it
came back
up again you know we hit through by a
couple of uh ticks early in that session
yesterday then lateer in the session we
broke through it again but then we
rallied back right up into it right so
you know what's going to happen when
you're trading above the value area one
is you're going to come down test it and
then go up two is you're going to test
it trade sideways or three you're going
to come down test the low and then break
and you get these big breaks sometimes
like that you know so boom you know
again I'm not saying you would you would
have sold it right here and covered it
down here of course not but you know
there was there was a lot of meat that
you could have got something out of
there you know that's why I'm spending a
lot of time talking about even though
the way I'm trying to explain it is
probably more confusing than anything
but uh but anyway you know that's that's
the beauty of of using orderflow and
using um you know Market profile volume
profile if I don't really talk much
about Market profile but you know
orderflow really is an extension of of
Market profile volume profile is
extension of Market profile be honest
with you it's not um you know something
completely different you know it gets a
lot of its uh thought process from from
it but again you know if if you're a
price action Trader oh yeah you know you
have this big green candle up here and
this and
that and you know what happens instead
of keep going up we hit this area and we
break through this value area and come
off anyway um let me just uh digress
here back
into simple orderflow say simple
orderflow but you know regular orderflow
and NASDAQ this morning so you know just
after the cash open open we had uh you
know we we had made a high right on the
cash started selling off selling off
selling off now this is where things got
interesting okay so you got Delta
scalper giving you a sell right here
coming down and down down down I I was
talking about this in the room you got
Delta minus 400 184 15501 169 46 so it's
getting weaker on this move down okay so
what you should be looking for is is a
bit of a bounce if you're going to get a
turn and some positive Delta strung
together so right on the low you got
negative Delta the bar turns up right
which sort of this bar Delta Divergence
and next bar you got Delta scalper
kicking off with the nice positive Delta
and even follows up in the next bar and
you get a nice move back
up you know right there boom boom boom
it does go higher um so that was that
was a nice one you know that that was a
simple you know orderflow I say it's not
a setup but it's or a pattern but you
know that's how reading the order
flow you know you see these things
happening
in in the markets every
day next one I thought about is uh five
years now this was interesting this was
this morning um about 5 in the morning
you're coming into the low here in the 5
years you got some strong selling coming
in you got you know the selling and
balance a little bit just off your lows
boom boom boom make new lows and right
on your low what do you got youve got
ratio and Divergence I talk about it
every single day and you know today I've
got a bunch to show you but um more
importantly you also had the Stacked
buying imbalance right off the low I I
love stack buying IM balances off lows I
love stack selling IM balances off highs
you know that's where you want to be
looking for them they don't always
happen there but when they do you know
they're quite powerful things have
changed you you com into this low all of
a sudden you got a very aggressive
buyers coming in and you get a nice move
up here um eventually you sold off I
mean there's things here in the AOL you
got ratio bonds low you got this red
arrow indicating um you know some trap
Traders up here you rally back up here
got some more trap Traders and then you
mark it the sells off come down here
Delta scalper gives a buy and we start
to Rally we start to Rally but what
happens is it falls apart and yeah I I
remember this again this was uh during
the room time here you have these very
strong buying you got buying IM balances
1400 5,000 which is decent you know in
in the 5 years but what happens is so
you got aggressive buyers right you're
coming up off your low aggressive buying
coming in buying IM balance 5,000 here
5,000 there and so you have strong
buyers then what happens the buying just
stops right these aggressive buyers are
no longer there
and also the market starts dropping you
know even 284 trade here then you look
in stacked uh not stacked sell imbalance
but it's a multiple imbalances in the
bar 1,800 1400 600 so you know some of
these people that were buying it here on
this way up are realizing hey you know
what this move is not happening we're
not going higher they turn sellers here
the market sells off down to new lows um
but you know this to me this was
very key you know I did think when we
couldn't go higher could have muster
move higher here you have positive Delta
4,000 you should be trading you know 05
right now instead of trading 02 A2 and
you know I said you know once the sell
once the buyers once the aggressive
buyers were realizing you know
we're wrong and one they stopped buying
and two they turn sellers that's why you
got these sell IM balances immediately
afterwards you know 1 2 3 4 here and go
down into new lows so you know you got
people that were long and wrong
basically getting out and covering their
loss and you don't have the aggressive
buyers you know basically bidding up the
market anymore and the market just
naturally falls down
got talk about buns really quick uh so
again you came up here I mean this was
this was a bit uh interesting here in
the Buns this high this was uh 2 in the
morning 2:46 this morning um again you
know it don't matter if it's 2:46 you
know in the Buns I I realize a lot of
people aren't in the US are asleep at
this time but you know for example
purposes I want to talk about this
because you know in case you see it
during uh something developed like this
during the US session so you got a
Divergence right here you got the high
at the negative Delta get a ratio it's
27.5 now it's very close to you know
what I like but you know we'll call it
as as not a not a
ratio but you get a ratio in the next
bar zero it's a black one now there's
two types of zero prints you basically
if you have a zero on top it'll be black
if it's a zero on the second spot it'll
be uh blue but again if it's a zero to
me it's still a ratio so you get a
Divergence and a ratio in the next bar
and you sell off again you I talk about
that setup every day every day every day
now again and you know look at this high
so from this high
246 negative Delta negative Delta
negative Delta negative Delta negative
Delta negative Delta negative Delta all
the way out here for the you know from
246 to
338 um then Delta scer gives a cell here
and what happens is you just keep going
sideways you know negative Delta one
positive Delta here but again you know
you have the Delta scalper is reading
honestly it came in I say it came in
late you know I would have liked to see
the delta scul or somewhere up in here
but um you know it's it's reading the
Delta and doing the analysis for you
then finally you know the selling is
just too much you know the buyer I can't
take it anymore and then you get your
move so you get your move from you know
from
16238 you know all the way down here to
18 that's a quick 20 20 ticks um you
know bounces up a little bit to 28 um
before it comes back down here to the 16
level but again you know watch watch
what's happening in the
Delta when you hit the highs you know
it's just stringing all this negative
Delta in here all negative Delta all
negative
Delta and then it finally breaks okay so
uh the next Market this is meal soy meal
okay I'm going to show you guys I show
you guys these different markets
sometimes because I I want to show you
that yeah you know orderflow Works in
other markets not just uh snps or bonds
or euro currency or crude you
know grains to me is are are great
contracts to trade because they really
follow supply and demand very well
especially you know grains are are more
driven by commercial Traders than
uh let me restart over grains are more
driven by spine demand because you have
it's dominated majority of the
participants are commercials you know
and they don't sit there um Inay tring
most of these things the amount of
intraday speculation in some of these
contracts is is a lot less than you're
going to get in in in crude oil and uh
snps so but again you know looking for
the same things you know Divergence okay
Divergence okay but you know I want more
right I want my I want a ratio
afterwards you know here you got
Divergence in a ratio just went sideways
okay fair enough Delta scalper give a
buy go up to new highs ratio and
Divergence right on the high and you get
a nice little sell off here going into
the close so the same thing I'm looking
for you know Delta scalper I'm looking
at the ratios and Divergence in this
case today you didn't have any point of
controls on the extreme but I'd be
looking for the same things you know
stacked imbalances everything okay so
that was crude oil sorry that was soy
meal crude oil I'll be looking at the
same thing here you got a
ratio and uh Divergence and you get a
nice little move up come back up here to
test the High um you know before you
come back down again so you know you had
really what I like to look for right
okay so I got this bearish signal here
ratio Divergence look for the move to
happen immediately right it's yeah it's
nice to get this pullback up here and
then a move down you know look for the
move to happen over the next two bars
when it pulls up like this pulls back
and then makes a move lower you this is
the time I'm looking to get out as any
any sign that the market is starting to
pull back because I don't expect the
move what what I don't expect to happen
is I got my bearish signal here we make
a move here you know you're talking move
from about 12 down to you know double O
so it's about you know 10 12 ticks pulls
back up here you that's assuming I just
get in here anyhow get in
aggressively and then pulls back up and
then makes the same sort of move here a
little bit lower and then starts pulling
back I'm not going to look for it to
come back down and make another move
like this you know maybe come down to
no give you One Shot Two Shots don't
wait for a third shot you know yeah I
would like to move to be bigger right
I'd love it to be from 4912 down to you
know 4850 but you know it just wasn't
happening you you met some buying in
here rallied back up you got another
push lower okay great that's a gift get
out if you're still in it um you know
don't don't sit there and and hope and
pray that it's going to go lower and you
know as as expected it started rallying
back up
here okay so last market I'll talk about
here really quick is the uh EUR
currency 6C so uh you know just going
back to the European open I mean you got
good volume in you know in the euro
currency you pretty much trade it from
the European
open and you know looking for some signs
yeah you got a point of control on the
extreme but you know I prefer this at a
swing High not you know it's not really
a swing high you're just you know one
two three bars up but uh you know
nevertheless uh you know Market did come
off I I I I wouldn't take that trade
just as I wouldn't take this one um then
you know a little bit later 247 off your
low Delta scalper gives a buy comes down
here gets a little bit below this low so
you know probably would stop out um then
Delta scalper sell you come up here you
test the high didn't get stopped out now
you know for this Delta scalper right
people ask where to put your stop put
your stop just above this High that's
how we draw out this area this is sort
of the uh you know the red line you know
like the RPM reader on your car once you
start trading up in here that's where
you could start uh managing the trade
and decide to get out just like here you
know we just came right back down really
quick actually get down here you know
it you know this is where you get
out you know take your loss look for
your next trade and you know here you
know it starts making the move down then
it starts ticking up ticking up in here
hey warning warning Red Alert um
fortunately it held it didn't get past
that you got a single print there price
rejector and then the market uh you know
continued its move down into uh new lows
get down here you have a ratio bounds
low you don't have a Divergence um you
do rally back up though so you know
again you know being short read the
order flow right where do you want to
get out he I got a bullish signal here I
got a racial bounds low telling me
there's some stopping volume down here
in this bar at this low you know that
that's your sign to get out you know you
don't have to wait for it to come all
the way up here to stop you out you know
take your profit you know whatever you
know little profit you can get out of it
you know maybe about eight ticks 10
ticks you know but that's your sign
right I mean that's why you read order
for it's not like okay I'm going to set
arbitrary take profit down here at uh 17
135 and if it doesn't get there I'll
just wait for it to stop me out no you
know you read the order flow and find
out what's going to happen you know and
make your decisions off that um a bit
later again similar thing you got Delta
scalper kicking off here starts making
the move down rallies back up again it's
holding in the zone that's why we draw
out you know that's why I have this Zone
programmed in there is it's to me it's a
it's a mental you
know mental uh what do you call it
you know mental stop or you know I mean
you could you could literally place your
stop there but you know for me it's you
I like to read the order flow so you you
see how it comes right back up to that
level of this area right because this
it's telling you you know they were
selling you know it shifted from Supply
from a demand driven Market to a supply
driven market and you come right back up
to these areas you're going to see the
sellers come in if this is going to hold
and what happens boom you get a nice
sell off again from this area up here
around 57 Boom come down into new low
lows new lows new lows uh new lows new
lows no reason to be buying down
here you know at these lows you know
then down here you get Delta scaler
again you know it it uh hits this
low Delta scaler kicks off a little bit
of a rally comes down here you got a
ratio and Divergence one bar up one bar
up and then just sort of goes sideways
on you before going um you know going
lower but again you know fact that just
makes its move and then just sort of
comes back down and goes sideways on you
you know at this point you know you
should 40 minutes later realize it's not
working out you got your move you're
just making lower
highs you know all these are signs you
know when you put the pieces of the
puzzles together right you got your you
got your trigger
here then goes up goes up goes up you
got a swing High here I guess I mean
it's not much of a swing High come off
rally back up can't take out this high
and you got a single print come off
again rally back up still can't take out
this high now so you're getting um lower
highs before you finally break down into
into new
lows you just a Divergence no ratio
there um again same thing ratio bounds
low here you get to pop
up yeah it's 7:30 okay you in here 7:15
again I'm not looking at take trades at
715 because you got to hold it through
the number number comes out yeah I can
make the argument oh look you know
there's a point of control extreme and
the market came off no you know you
wouldn't be trading at 7:30 you
shouldn't be taking signals around 730
now later you know 750 here you start
coming off again you got Delta scoper
giving you a
cell and you know it makes its move you
know it's it's small move before it
starts rallying back up
unfortunately you know sometimes the
moves are big sometimes they're
unfortunately
uh smaller again you get Delta scoper
giving you a sell here now here you get
a nice you get a better move than the
one before you know from uh 11703 down
to 90 89 even
lower point of control extreme right
here bullish ratio unfortunately it runs
into the bar with a single print here
four you you got a bearish ratio as well
which you know again you you get
something this is what
I Insight here for you you get you know
a high or a low made you got a bullish
ratio you know ratio bonds low anything
if the next bar is got the opposite uh
you know either a bearish ratio you got
bullish ratio here it's followed by a
bearish ratio chances are it's not going
to work out on you um so you know keep
that in mind right I'm that's you know
it it's what you want to see you want to
see continuation you don't want to come
in with the the red bar after this this
bar you don't want to come in with the
opposite thing here with the bearish
ratio um majority of the time it's going
to fail on you and this trade fails then
here you get the Delta scoper right off
the low Delta scoper coming in um boom
right off the low this is uh you know
11688 and we you know rally all the way
up to uh you know almost
117 even do get up through it but uh you
know it's it's taking its time
unfortunately it's taking its time to to
Really uh you you get the will pop up
then you just sort of go
sideways but you know eventually you do
uh you do rally quite
nicely um you know then late in the day
double Delta scalper one two single
print here so you got this basically
this you know triple High almost not
almost it is but um ratio Delta scalper
Delta scalper and then you make a nice
little move down um going into the close
for the day but again you know this
one's curring you know quite late in the
day I I'm I'm not a big fan of trading
currencies after 2 p.m. you know the old
floor Clos and basically when cash
dealers close their books for the day
but you know you still can get moves you
know it's up to you if you want to trade
during that time
so you know those are the tools used in
the presentation orderflows Trader and
the Delta scalper and again if you're
interested uh to learn more about the
software go to overflow.com and go to
Deltas scaler.com so thanks everyone
bye-bye